Let's talk about building your actual asset in what you should use.
Now I don't personally care what you use.
It can be WordPress, it can be Wix, it can be Weebly, it can be any of the above.
It doesn't matter.
It can be Squarespace or whatever new thing they come out with after I recorded this video.
It really doesn't matter, but what I want you to think about for a minute is this.
Let's talk about a custom home builder and let's talk about a spec home behemoth like
DR Horton or one of these national companies.
Now the custom home builder builds a very beautiful pretty home.
They go in, they get these customers and they're like, hey, where do you want the wall and
what do you want on this one and how do you want the bathroom and they're these beautiful
homes.
But there's so much work into it, there's so much effort into it that they can only
build 10 or 15 of these a year.
Whereas a DR Horton, they're like, hey, we've got four homes and you can choose one of the
four homes, you can choose one of the four finishes, you can choose one of these carpets,
one of these paints and they knock them out and they knock them out and they knock them
out and they knock them out and even though the DR Horton home isn't as beautiful as the
custom home, I would love to see the guy that owns DR Horton, I would love to see his house
and his bank account versus Mr. Joe Schmo custom home builder.
So it's the same thing as McDonald's, in fact, fun little fact here, I was reading this book
last night, The Cash Flow Quadrant by old Robert Kiyosaki, my boy and he was talking
about this and he was talking about McDonald's, right?
Could you or can you think of five or ten places that make better hamburgers than McDonald's?
I can and I don't even like hamburgers but can you think of a single place that has a
better system than the McDonald's that can churn out a hamburger that is the same hamburger
here as it is in Ghana, West Africa or here as it is in New York City or here as it is
in Australia?
You can't.
So the game is we're here to make money and we don't need to get emotionally attached
to how these websites look because that's not where the money is, the money is in getting
the phone to ring and getting another client and getting more deals.
So with that said, I just want you to know it doesn't matter what you use, it only matters
that you master what you do and you figure out how to do it quickly and efficiently and
it converts, okay?
So we are going to show you, I'm gonna have Francesca is gonna jump in here in just a
moment.
She's gonna show you what we use and everything that we're gonna teach you in these modules
is what my agency Evergreen does and has done and has used to go from what we were doing
which is almost nothing to seven figures.
So I'm gonna let her jump in and show you how to get that set up.
We personally use Weebly.
Okay, so I'm going to show you how to create a designer Weebly account.
So you are going to search for designers.weebly.com register and you're going to end up on this
page right here and you're going to fill out this information.
So we already have an account, I'm just going to show you how to create your own.
Make sure you are on designer Weebly and not just Weebly, they are different.
The designer one lets you do a lot more things in depth.
So make sure you are on that one.
So you're going to fill out your information.
I'm just doing a quick, quick one and boom, pretty easy.
And now I'm going to log it into our own account.
This was just to show you how this one would be created.